um
uh
cups
good
that's what it is
okay
so
this is
good morning everyone thanks for coming
we'll start about two minutes
so please have your phones on silent
actually a minute
did you need a white still a white
balancer
sometimes
[Music]
she's really nice
um
good morning i'm lieutenant ray spencer
i'm the homicide lieutenant with the las
vegas metropolitan police department
thank you for coming out here this
morning for this very important press
conference
but before i begin i do want to thank
several agencies that have been
a tremendous help for us over the last
six days
specifically the clark county school
district police department
the fbi the nye county sheriff's office
the national center for missing
exploited children
the homeland security investigations the
u.s
border patrol the clark county family
services
and also the henderson police department
the point of this conference today is we
wanted to make sure
we got the most up-to-date information
to the public
to help us identify the child
who was murdered and left in mountain
springs
on friday morning through the last
several days we've been working with the
national
center in an effort to update the
photograph
to truly depict the weight of the victim
this is an updated digitally enhanced
photograph
that captures the gap in the child's
teeth we feel it captures his weight
because again he is 4 foot 11 123 pounds
we believe the age is going to be 8 to
10 years of age
so again this is the newest photographs
that are
have been provided please share those
photographs
any tip regardless of how small we are
following up on
in an effort to identify
who he is with that i do want to
turn it over we have a very important
announcement that the
fbi is here to share with you today and
i'll turn it over
to them at this point
good morning the fbi works with our law
enforcement partners and private sector
partners on a daily basis and this case
is going to be no different
we're currently offering award of up to
ten thousand dollars
for information leading to the
identification
of john little zion doe or information
leading to the identification of the
subject or person of interest
related to his death this child has a
right to be referred to by his given
name
he's someone's son someone's grandson
and he deserves law enforcement's
commitment to solving this case
children are most vulnerable population
and we're dedicated to assisting the las
vegas metropolitan police department
in anything they need and to help with
this investigation
we're counting on the public to help us
with his identification
and no lead is too small with regards to
any information that we can get
we're asking that the public contact
1-800
call fbi or we'll also accept online
tips
through tips.fbi.gov and we will not
stop or rest
until the identity of him is determined
or until his subject is captured thank
you
again we're very very thankful for the
assistance from the fbi and the reward
money
that is available so again with that i
will take a couple questions if you have
them